und dann hat eine Partei namens Moment
AFD diese Woche ihren zehnten Geburtstag
gefeiert da fällt mir gerade ein ich
habe ja überhaupt keine Einladung
gekriegt
es wahrscheinlich noch in der Post
anders kann ich mir nicht erklären ja
zehn Jahre AFD man könnte auch sagen die
Alternative ist jetzt endlich altpartei
herzlichen Glückwunsch auch von mir ja
zehn Jahre Gezeter gegen die da oben und
plötzlich gehört man selber zum Bett das
muss ausgelassen gefeiert werden gucken
Sie mal auf diese Decke als hätte der
Architekt geahnt dass hier mal die AFD
feiern will genau das blaue ist nämlich
die Farbe der Partei und so sieht's aus
wenn sie feiern
wow die haben ja gefeiert als gäbe es
keinen Morgen
vom Alter Schnitt her stimmt das für
einige sogar
Spaß ich bin selber alt die AFD sitzt im
Bundestag und in 15 von 16
Landesparlamenten mit anderen Worten man
hatte sich in dem System dass man
eigentlich weg haben will ganz schön
muckelig gemacht über die Jahre ja
inklusive Diäten und Fuhrpark 10 Jahre
Kampf gegen Eliten inklusive der Medien
die sogar am Geburtstag voll böse sind
Fragen dazu jetzt an Timo krupala der in
Weißwasser in Sachsen ist guten Morgen
guten Morgen und vielen Dank für die
Glückwünsche
die ich nicht wirklich geäußert habe
sondern jetzt gibt es Fragen
ja cool Fragen als Geschenk ne
ist besser als Socken oder
hundekrawatten würde ich sagen übrigens
von den 18 AFD Gründungsvätern sind
heute nur noch drei in der Partei und
Bernd Lücke würde am liebsten vergessen
dass er der erste afd-chef war das ist
ja auch kein Wunder
eine der der rechte Flügel um Bernd
höcke hat ihn erst die Partei und dann
den Vornamen geklaut
fakt ist die AFD von heute wissen sie
muss sich gar nicht mehr aufwendig
bürgerlicht haben die sind als völkische
Bewegung inzwischen bei sich angekommen
und stehen trotzdem
oder deswegen in Umfragen bei um die 15
Prozent dank der aktuellen Krisen das
ist ein ganz interessantes Phänomen dass
die selbst ernannten großen Patrioten
immer nur gedeihen wenn das Land
ausreichend Probleme hat zehn Jahre AFD
der Staatsfunk liegt ergriffen zurück
2013 ein wunderbares Jahr Corona war
noch eine Biermarke die Russen waren die
guten und Friedrich Merz saß Kekse
futternd in aufsichtsreiten alles toll
bis zum 6 Februar denn dann Gründe dann
hoffen Opas mit zu viel Tagesfreizeit
eine Partei sie sind gegen Pleite
Griechen und hassen Energiesparlampen
warum auch immer und eine obskure
Sendung namens heute show schenkt der
Partei von Anfang an Sendezeit warum
aber ich habe davon nichts gewusst genau
das sagen die deutschen hinterher immer
doch schon kurz danach beginnen die
Säuberungen ein Vorsitzender nach dem
anderen verschwindet spurlos ach nee
warte mal bei denen kommt das erst noch
Strippenzieher und eigentlicher
Machthaber ist und bleibt einer von
diesen beiden Bernds ein Mann der uns
viel mehr erzählt als wir wissen wollen
mein Vater ist jetzt eine Frau
glückwunsch das alles weil heute show
history höckes Helfer
ja
demnächst im ZDF
endlich
endlich mal ein ZDF history ohne Hitler
ist das überhaupt erlaubt ich weiß es
nicht aber von wegen die AFD hat nichts
bewirkt gerade für eine Partei die den
Menschen gemacht und Klimawandel leugnet
haben die das politische Klima aber
massiv gewandelt ich sage nur neue
Ordnungsruf Rekorde im Bundestag da wird
gepöbelt so die berühmte Grenze des
Sagbaren verläuft jetzt irgendwo hinter
der oder Neiße Linie ne oder ist das
alles ein furchtbares Missverständnis
und die AFD ist viel sanfter als wir
denken wir haben uns klar als
Friedenspartei aufgestellt als
friedensfraktion und auch als
Friedenspartei und wir sind die einzig
wahrnehmbare Friedenspartei
friedensfraktion aktiv für den Frieden
als Friedenspartei und wir sind für
Frieden ein bisschen Frieden Sonne
[Musik]
ach ja AFD friedenshippies wo sind die
Wasserwerfer wenn man sie mal braucht
Putins Liebste Friedenspartei steht top
da in den Umfragen
26% in Thüringen
29% in Sachsen in beiden Ländern wird
nächstes Jahr gewählt da darf man schon
mal anfangen zu träumen beziehungsweise
allzu träumen
unintelligible die neue Kanzlerpartei zu
werden
[Musik]
hey
der Tusch war nicht von uns wirklich
und der Gaga auch nicht ja die AFD als
neue reichskanzlerpartei redet jetzt
öffentlich vom mitregieren das ist ein
bisschen gefährlich denn in irgendeiner
Regierungskoalition müsste man
Kompromisse machen und zack hast einen
die eigene radikale Basis ich sage in
Wirklichkeit wollen die doch gar nicht
regieren nein weil es für sie viel
geiler ist immer nur zum Meckern ohne
selber Verantwortung zu übernehmen
dieser Gag wurde Ihnen präsentiert von
deutsche Satire wir meckern auch nur
das stimmt aber selbst wenn ich mich
irre und die AFD will wirklich regieren
bleibt ja doch noch ein winziges
Problemchen mit wem die Union sagt also
mit uns auf keinen Fall zwischen uns und
der AFD steht nämlich eine Brandmauer
für dich März spricht ja von Brandmauern
die aufgebaut hat und gerade wie
ostdeutschen wissen wie man mit Mauern
umgeht wir können diese sehr wohl und
sehr gut einreißen
ich mag sein natürliches Lächeln
spannende Frage hält die berühmte
Brandmauer zu AFD tatsächlich grenzt
sich die mehr CDU klar nach rechts ab
Beispiel das Parteiausschlussverfahren
gegen Hans-Georg Maaßen das jetzt wohl
kommt ist ja die Meldung der Woche
Meldung der Woche der ehemalige
verfassungsschutzchef und Vorsitzender
der werteunion wird quasi aus der Partei
exorziert ausgetrieben ist das klug und
vor allem kann das klappen fragen wir
einen der wissen muss Klaus von Wagner
Klaus von Wagner der Exorzist den die
Parteien vertrauen
ja meine Damen Klaus von Wagner ist
tatsächlich Deutschlands einziger
Parteien Exorzist Hochwürden wie
schätzen Sie das ein könnten sie der CDU
den Maßen austreiben
ich bete zum Herrn dass dieser Kelch an
mir vorübergehen mag damals bei Thilo
Sarrazin wäre ich fast gestorben dann
kam Palma der furchtbare Besserwisser
aus Tübingen direkt aus der Hölle
und ich meine bei Maßen da müsste man ja
zunächst überhaupt erstmal klären ob
dieser Typ überhaupt da echt extrem ist
in Interviews spricht er von grün-roter
Rassenlehre Rassismus der gegen die
Einheimischen Deutschen betrieben werde
ich kritisiere dass hier Menschen ins
Land gebracht werden teilweise aus
rassistischer Motivation so sehe ich das
so sieht er das gut vielleicht ist die
Brille doch einfach zu klein ja also
hast du gut mein Wasser wir müssten dann
vielleicht
weiter da müsste ich ja auch gleich die
komplette werteunion mit austreiben das
dauert doch zu ewig ich arbeite jetzt
schon an einer endlosenliste von
Besessenen die nicht freiwillig gehen
wollen morgen treffe ich zum Beispiel
den Wolken in Köln
da wünsche ich viel Glück aber sie haben
da natürlich einen Punkt der Fahrer mit
mit Maßen schmeißt man natürlich einen
aus der CDU der durchaus Fans hat vor
allem in bestimmten
Gegenden Moment das ist doch das ist
doch
also ich will mal so sagen manche Ideen
sind nicht schlecht
ich würde mal so sagen überraschendes
Ende ja sieht man nicht kommen aber
jetzt bitte nicht wieder dummes Aussehen
auch im Westen gibt es werteunion
Mitglieder die trotz allem zu Maßen
halten die CDU hat den noch 2021 als
Bundestagskandidaten für Südthüringen
aufgestellt und wer hat ihn damals
verteidigt als er in Chemnitz durch
seine minibälle partout keine Hetzjagden
sehen wollte wer
die Grünen
nein nicht die Grünen Horst Seehofer
selber erst als Maßen angefangen hat von
Citat
linksradikalen in der SPD zu faseln hat
der Horst merkt dass der Mann vollkommen
abgedrehte sich meine linke
Kinder SPD
also jetzt doch Exorzismus für Maßen
also Ausschlussverfahren
ja wieder kostenlose Aufmerksamkeit und
davon ernähren sich ja die meisten
Dämonen abgesehen davon damit wäre das
Problem ja nicht aus der Partei der CDU
Bürgermeister von Bautzen z.B hat
letzten Herbst bei einer sogenannten
Mahnwache unter anderem vor freien
Sachsen und anderen rechtsextremen
gesprochen sogar März der große
Vorsitzende flirtet gelegentlich mit der
anderen Seite der Brandmauer das stimmt
das hat ihm ja gerade die Strack
Zimmermann im Aachener Karneval
ordentlich ein mitgegeben aber ich finde
das mit Humor genommen also sagt
zumindest sein Gesicht
nach außen bürgerlicher Schein im Herzen
aber voll gemein
wer vor Krieg geflohen ist verhöhnt er
als sozialtourist heißt ein Junge Ali
und nicht Sascha beschimpfte ihn als
grundschulpascha
ich würde sagen für einen Sauerländer
war das quasi ein Lachflash
absolut ja ich habe auch der und die
straki werden bestimmt noch dicke
Freunde und was machen wir jetzt mit
Maßen ja was wohl das kennen sie aus dem
Kino am Ende muss sich der Exorzist im
Opfern und den bösen Geist zu sich
locken es geht leider nicht anders sagt
man dann sowas wie nie mich waschen nimm
mich verschone die CDU und verschlinge
meine Seelen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
eingetreten damit 1,8 Millionen Euro
nach Deutschland kommen
Klaus von Wagner meine Damen und
[Applaus]
hallo leute wenn ihr jetzt auf Gefällt
mir drückt und den Kanal abonniert zeige
ich euch meinen lautesten Schrei für das
menschliche Gehör ist der zwar nicht
wahrzunehmen aber ich würde eure Hunde
kurz rausbringen okay fertig